sur footballeur moyen chers footballeurs
américains ou pas le temps d ouais je
suis content j'ai marqué un super
touchdown c'est fini si je vous dis
supporter ou hamburger vous pouvez me
dire ce coeur mais vous me direz surtout
foot us une religion au pays de l'oncle
sam avec en point d'orgue
comme chaque début février le super bowl
la finale du championnat de nfl le plus
grand show sportif au monde avec cette
année à la mi temps
jennifer lopez et shakira non non non le
super bowl c'est aussi et surtout 110
millions de téléspectateurs 5,1 millions
de dollars pour 30 secondes de publicité
à la télé 1,25 milliard de chicken wings
vendu le super bowl c'est aussi de la
politique entre les tweets de donald
trump et les messages engagés des
sportifs
bref foot us sport politique ou business
on en parle après le général
[Musique]
bienvenue sur rt france pour un nouvel
épisode de l'autre match consacré cette
semaine aux 54e super bowl
il va avoir lieu ce week-end à miami ce
sera à suivre sur bien sport à partir de
23h30 et aux commentaires il y aura vous
marc angelo soumah bonjour je vous êtes
consultant dont bin sport mais surtout
ancien joueur de nfl du côté de
cleveland et même ancien président de la
fédération française de foot américain
bonjour et bienvenue à vos côtés à
gérald olivier vous êtes journaliste
franco américain à spécialiste des états
unis de la politique américaine
chercheur associé à l'iris l'institut
prospective sécurité en europe et auteur
du livre à paraître sur la route de la
maison blanche aux éditions jean
picollec bonjour également bienvenus
messieurs la question qu'on se pose on
l'a entendu dans l'édito c'est le foot
us qu est ce que c est ce que c'est du
sport est ce que c'est de la politique
est-ce que c'est du business on a posé
cette question à exactement 2007 120
personnes sur les réseaux sociaux sur rt
france et le résultat c'est celui ci 26
% de personnes pensent qu'il s'agit de
sport 69% pensent qu'il s'agit de
business d'économies et cinq portions de
politique pour vous marc angelo c'est
quoi le superbe région ce que vous
auriez même peut-être pu ajouter
est ce qu'il s'agit de religion parce
que quand on est au texas
il ya deux choses qui comptent qui
soutiennent la vie c'est un l'église de
football américain donc forcément le
football américain représente beaucoup
pour eux et la ligue s'est construite
autour bien sûr du sport mais aussi aux
constructeurs du business c'est à dire
que rapidement on s'est dit il faut que
le sport soit rentable étant donné qu'on
n'est pas dans une économie française où
on est subventionné par l'état
il devait s'en sortir tout seul et donc
forcément le business et la rentabilité
a eu son mot à dire
business is business donc pour vous un
marc angelo et pour vous gérald ou alors
moi j'aurais rajouté un autre terme
c'est du spectacle
j'ai du spectacle c'est un spectacle
basé sur le sport mais c'est d'abord un
spectacle est d'ailleurs les joies de
légende la nfl considère que les matchs
du dimanche ça s'appelle un show donc
c'est vraiment un spectacle et l'idée
c'est un spectacle pour les gens qui
sont dans le stade
la très belle image qui a derrière vous
et puis surtout aujourd'hui un spectacle
télévisé et la réalité du football
américain ce qui est particulier c'est
que c'est un sport dont les règles
semble avoir été écrite pour la
télévision
c'est à dire que vous avez une
succession d'actions qui sont
extrêmement rapides extrêmement
spectaculaire et qui sont interrompus
parce qu'on a plusieurs tentatives en
gagnent du terrain progressivement à
chaque interruption
la télévision vous repasse le ralenti de
l'action précédente que vous allez
disséqués c'est un spectacle formidable
et c'est un spectacle qui a conquis
l'amérique au cours des cinquante
soixante dix dernières années et qui est
devenu le premier spectacle télévisuel
aux états unis depuis une bonne
vingtaine d'années
en tous les cas ce spectacle génère
beaucoup d'argent
l'économie du football américain du
super bowl en particulier c'est avec les
mandats coire 5000 journalistes
accrédités une diffusion dans 180 pays
le super bowl c'est l'événement majeur
de ce début d'année et l'économie qui
l'entourent peut faire perdre la tête
les recettes publicitaires devrait
atteindre les 350 millions de dollars
pour seulement quatre heures d'antenne
sur le terrain une prime de 90 mille
dollars sera attribué pour les
vainqueurs contre 50 milles pour les
perdants côté par un sportif 5 milliards
de dollars avait été parier illégalement
sur la rencontre de l'an dernier au
total les américains devraient dépenser
près de 15 milliards de dollars dont une
partie non négligeable dans la
nourriture
les fans devraient avaler 1,25 milliard
d'elle de poulet près de 14000 500
tonnes de chips accompagnés de huit
millions de kilos de guacamole
quoi frôler l'indigestion n'ai pas de
problème pour certains puisque un
américain sur dix n'ira pas travailler
le lendemain un marc angelo on dit
souvent que les états unis seul pays de
la démesure quand on voit ces chiffres
c'est le cas ils sont beaucoup ils sont
beaucoup plus nombreux que nous mais oui
il ya des moments où les américains qui
travaillent beaucoup se disent là on va
se lâcher là on va pouvoir
ils travailleront pas le lendemain ce
sera l'inde exactement le nid du super
bowl où tout est permis on peut
justement va profiter avec ses amis bien
manger et on je prends un jour de repos
le lendemain un américain sur dix ne
travaillera pas le lendemain les neuf
autres ils font quoi ils regardent pas
le super bowl la veille ou pas ils font
trop la fête c'est un lendemain de fête
le super bowl est programmée un dimanche
et à cause de la télévision il est
programmé de plus en plus tard le
dimanche parce qu'aux états unis vous
avez une une fenêtre de télévision qui
s'appelle le prime time qui est celle où
il ya le plus de téléspectateurs et qui
en gros va de 18h à 21h donc on va
programmer le match aussi tard que
possible pour qu'il passe en prime time
et les gens continuent à faire la fête
au delà du match vous avez beaucoup
parlé des chip du wac au mollet il ya de
la bière derrière beaucoup beaucoup de
bière donc je crois de 52 millions de
packs de bière on ne sait pas combien il
ya de bouteilles ou canettes dans les
packs deuxième aux états unis mais voilà
ça fait quand même beaucoup
on a on a vu 1 15 milliard de dollars
c'est ce que vont dépenser des
américains en marge du superbowl
ces 15 milliards gerin d'olivier profite
à qui sait quoi l'économie du land vous
l'avez vu c'est principalement de la
nourriture dit profite aux transports il
profite à l'industrie hôtelière parce
que malgré tout la ville qui est la
ville hôte du super bowl voit une marée
humaine se déverser et pas simplement le
jour du match le super bowl ça dure une
semaine là le match aura lieu dans trois
jours mais ça fait une semaine qu'à
miami c'est la fête tous les soirs que
vous avez des défilés que vous avez des
marques qui sont venus pour faire des
promotions de ce que les joueurs qui
sont ici sont liés par des contrats mais
aussi des obligations professionnelles
dont vous avez un grand rendez-vous de
business autour du super bowl et le
match c'est en quelque sorte je crois en
hiver c'est le dernier événement d'une
montée en puissance économique qui va
bien au-delà de ce qui se passe sur le
terrain le dimanche soir mais les gens
qui vont
qui vont aller au stade pour voir cette
finale entre les kansas city chiefs et
les fortunes diverses de san francisco
ceux qui vont au stade c'est qui c'est
les gens qui sont fortunés parce que le
prix du billet l'année dernière un prix
moyen c'était 4600 dollars ça commence à
3000 ça peut aller jusqu'à 15000 dollars
est-ce que la dichotomie là entre le
rêve américain et le super bowl c'est le
problème qu'ils avaient en fait c'est
que alors cette année je crois que c'est
à cinq ou six mille dollars la place et
en plus ils le marché parallèle où ça
peut monter jusqu'à 10,1 fn espère que
ça monte jusqu'à 10000 sur le marché
parallèle mais ça veut dire que dans le
stade mais proposé en précommande profi
te parler du marché par la même prime
permettez moi de vous couper il profite
à qui ce marché par à ceux qui peuvent
se le permettre
puis à des reventes un petit peu
compliqué et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
l'une des critiques qui est fait à la
nfl et au super bowl c'est que
l'événement lui même est devenu un
événement de classe il est réservé aux
gens qui savent s'y prendre aux gens qui
ont des réseaux aux gens qui ont des
moyens parce que là on parle du du
billet d'entrée du ticket d'entrée au
passage si vous achetez si vous n'avez
jamais les yeux ou les mains sur un
ticket de super bowl y'a pas le prix du
ticket parce qu'en fait il n'y a pas de
prix le prix c'est ce que vous êtes
prêts à payer pour rentrer sur le stade
pour avoir ici vous l'achetez de manière
officielle vous n'allez pas acheter le
billet vous allez acheter un package
vous allez acheter à un hôtel de luxe
vous allez acheter telle visite et on
vous fera ça à 15 20 25 mille dollars
donc c'est tout un événement les plus
malins sont ceux qui parviennent à
acheter des tickets et les revendre au
marché parallèle jamais les joueurs qui
font sens et comment comment
le vice à vous parliez tout à l'heure du
texas le texan moyens comment est ce
qu'il vise à ce qui va forcément
fortunés il ya une double participation
superbe audi a6 bien sûr dont on vient
de parler qui rentre au stade mais aussi
tout ce que la nfl a créé autour de
l'événement et vous parlez de la semaine
la semaine est jonché d'événements pour
tous les fans où les fans peuvent y
aller avec un droit d'entrée bien
entendu mais beaucoup moins que l'entrée
au super bowl ce qui fait que en fait ce
que vous allez faire c'est passé une
semaine à miami rencontrer des joueurs
de toutes les équipes qui vont passer
des événements des rencontres avec
l'équipe qui participent au super bowl
tout type d'événement pour les planques
pour les grands et pour les petits et
ensuite vous allez regarder le super
bowl ce qui fait que la participation au
super bowl c'est pas juste regarder le
match c'est pas ceux ci la semaine et
participer à la mi temps cette année va
y avoir des différends lepez chekir 1 et
l'année dernière il y avait lady gaga ça
aussi c'est un véritable show il ya
beaucoup de gens surtout dans le monde
qui regarde même pas le super bowl qui
regarde juste le show à la mi temps et
qui ensuite éteint la télé ou font autre
chose et ça fait partie de la
construction de l'expérience nfl vous
allez à une quand vous allez voir un
match
vous allez vivre une expérience qui
n'est pas juste le match de football n'a
qu'un qui est la manière dont reçoit des
animations autour pour vos enfants pour
vous le spectacle à la mi-temps le fait
que vous mangez bien tout cela ça fait
partie de l'expérience en effet les on
veut en faire profiter un maximum de
monde on ne dise pas juste ceux qui
aiment le football américain ou bizet la
famille on vise 300 snes pour toucher le
plus de monde possible évidemment et
faire le plus d'argent gérald olivier
oui oui en propre à la télévision tout à
l'heure je vous disais que c'est du
spectacle d'abord le half time shoah le
show de la mi temps il a été inventé à
ce qu'au début les premiers super bowl
n'y avait pas de show à la mi temps mais
il a été inventé par les chaînes de
télévision pour conserver l'audience
entre les deux mi temps c'est le
football c'est quatre quarts temps mais
en fait ces deux mi temps parce qu'on
joue deux quart temps puis après on ont
fait une pause et puis on reprend pour
les deux derniers quarts temps mais à la
mi temps vous avez du point de vue des
chaînes de télévision le risque que le
chômage indicateur aille se coucher il
est tard il est
il est tard sur la côte est et on
travaille parfois le lendemain et donc
il fallait garder le spectacle de
téléspectateurs devant l'écran il
fallait que madame vienne le hive thème
chaud il est conçu pour les dames c'est
parce que le sport lui même c'est un
truc de mecs excusez moi d'être un petit
peu schématique mais le football est un
sport de contact assez brutale et c'est
un sport est ce qu'on reste justement de
rosporden des sports dès qu'on est dans
cette année dans le spectacle magnifique
lac
c'est un spectacle sportif qui fait qu'
on a toute cette dimension sportive mais
en plus on y ajoute le spectacle pour
les chiens joueurs et joueurs c'est du
sport je voulais l'extrême en séance
vous en tant qu'ancien joueur quand vous
jouiez en effet le souvenir national
football league pour ceux qui ne savent
pas vous étiez dans votre tête vous
étiez quoi vous étiez sportifs acteurs
aux et il collabore entièrement sportif
d'ailleurs quand on commence à jouer au
football américain c'est pour l'aspect
sportif c'est juste qu'on évolue et on
passe dans une ligue où il y a d'autres
choses à côté mais par exemple on
accepte très bien en tant que joueur
quand vous jouez un match de football
américain il ya quelqu'un qui est sur le
bord du terrain au bout et qui avec
l'onglet orange delà jusqu'à là et quand
ils rentrent sur le terrain et qui fait
comme ça ça veut dire il ya une pub ça
veut dire vous pouvez pas jouer faut
attendre et tous les joueurs le savent
on comprend ça ça fait partie du
business c'est la contrepartie d'avoir
des contrats avec des salaires
intéressants
vous parliez tout à l'heure de
l'audience gérad olivier le record c'est
114 millions de téléspectateurs aux
états unis aux états unis si on regarde
l'audience globale dans le monde de la
finale de la coupe du monde de foot en
moscou en 2018 entre la france et la
croatie c'était un milliard
virgule 12 téléspectateurs au final
c'est quoi le plus grand le plus grand
show du mois je vous fais une confidence
j'ai pas les chiffres pour vous dire si
c'est une coupe de monde de foot au
soccer ou si c'est un super bowl qui a
la plus grande audience globale
vous avez indiqué 180 pays je pense que
je pour chaque super bowl
on n'est pas loin du milliard faut aussi
comprendre qu'il ya le décalage horaire
qui fait que c'est pas toujours un
horaire très pratique en france on n'est
pas très bien lotis parce que le match
commence il est minuit et demi on fait
vraiment avoir envie de le regarder
cela dit c'est global c'est d'ailleurs
un point intéressant et c'est une des
questions que personnellement je me pose
quand je regarde la nfl
si je me dis couval a en effet parce que
la nfl est une petite ligue
professionnelle vous aviez une dizaine
d'hommes d'affaires qui se sont mis
d'accord pour que des équipes de
football se rend compte et qu'on crée un
championnat c'est devenu ce qu'est la
nfl aujourd'hui que dans un business
absolument monumental rappelons qu'au
niveau global sur les équipes sportives
qui rapporte le plus seul un grenelle et
30 premières 25 sont de la nfl
manchester united milan ac le real
madrid
derrière ils sont pas dans la même ligue
et même en termes de ligue l'a aimée fed
et la ligue la plus allante en avant
table sarano de tous les sports
ce qui veut dire qu'ils sont devant ils
le savent ils ont dépassé le baseball
parce que pour oublier car à l'intérieur
du pays avait le baseball comme
concurrent est encore là une bille n est
chercheur il ya une sacrée concurrence à
domicile donc ils sont développés là
dessus au niveau des événements sportifs
ce que vous demandiez et bien les trois
événements qui apporte le plus d'audimat
finale de la coupe du monde
les jo en particulier le 100 m et le
super bowl initialement le tour de
france également qui fait vendre
inquiète très suivi oui messieurs j'ai
pas l'élégant orange et je vais pas vous
faire le signe parce que c'est l'heure
de la pause et on revient dans un
instant pour la suite de l'autre match
spécial super bowl
la mi temps lifetime comme on dit aux
états unis est passé nos invités sont
toujours présents sur ce plateau marc
angelo soumah vous êtes consultant been
sport in sport qui va diffuser le super
bowl ce week-end dimanche soir vous
serez là est à vos côtés gérald olivier
spécialiste des états unis parlaient de
ce côté business de cette audience
planétaire pour pour le super bowl à la
pause là on disait également qu' il n'y
a pas seulement le super bowl il ya
également d'autres soirs dans la semaine
qui sont très importants oui maintenant
on joue le jeudi soir on joue le
dimanche après midi entièrement et le
dimanche soir il ya sunday night la
fiche de la semaine et ensuite on a le
mal de match du lundi soir entre
parenthèses tout ça c'est diffusé sur
bin sport mais ça fait une masse
d'événements ou en fait à partir de
jeudi
et bien tout le monde est tourné vers la
nfl tout le monde est tourné vers la nfl
on suit les évolutions on suit comment
les joueurs vont s'adapter les blessures
qui va faire quoi
donc on est captif en fait c'est un
feuilleton à la photo est ce qu'il faut
ce qu'il faut comprendre également c'est
que dans le paysage télévisuel actuel où
on a eu une multiplication des chaînes
l'hommage de football est devenu
l'événement hebdomadaire qui rassemble
l'ensemble du pays autour d'un événement
aujourd'hui chacun garde sa chaîne mais
tout le monde regarde le football on
parle d'événements parle de séries de
fiction mais il ya des histoires à
l'intérieur même de l'histoire il ya de
la politique qui s'invite également dans
le superbowl un petit récap présenté par
clément delcourt
des spots de pub de 30 secondes pour
passer des messages politiques en plein
super bowl voilà la stratégie de
certaines marques en 2017
un an après l'élection de donald trump
l'immigration était au centre de
l'attention médiatique
airbnb budweiser est ici fort lomber ou
encore la plate forme de voyages expédia
affichée et au su du monde leur
désaccord avec la politique du président
américain la même année alors que la nfl
était secoué par l'action de collines
copernic la super star tom brady n'avait
pas hésité à critiquer donald trump
suite à ses propos sur les sportifs qui
posé un genou à terre pendant les hymnes
nationaux
pourtant très proche du président il
avait estimé que ces déclarations
diviser le pays
marc angelo soumah quand il ya plus de
110 millions de téléspectateurs on voit
le super bowl devient un vecteur de
communication de message est ce qu'il ya
pas là une dérive pour oublier le côté
sportif
j'aurais tendance à dire que cette
dérive il existe actuellement où vous
avez une plateforme où vous pouvez
toucher un maximum de personnes
facebook a eu ce problème là pour le
football américain à partir du moment où
tout le monde regarde le moment est
parfait pour parler d'autre chose
sans vraiment détourné du football et la
chaque joueur sait cela et donc veut
passer son message et on a eu la dérive
par rapport aux marques
on a eu pareil alors une dérive ou pas
est ce que on peut le dire ainsi par
rapport à comines cas pernik qui a passé
un message social à travers sa
plateforme sportive donc ancien joueur d
forty niners club ou franchise plutôt
c'est comme ça qu'on veut dire qu'il va
discuter donc le super bowl ce week-end
qui a mis le genou à terre pour
protester contre les violences
policières et puis ensuite il ya une
grosse polémique avec donald trump qui
s'en est mêlé gérald olivier oui
absolument
le problème c'est que les américains
aiment pas beaucoup quand le sport et la
politique se mélangent s'ils sont pas
forcément fan de politique ils suivent
la politique parce que sa comptine
évitables mans mais le dimanche c'est le
jour du seigneur le matin et c'est le
jour du sport l'après midi et ça faut le
respecter
et donc quand des sportifs qui sont très
bien payés
malgré les efforts qu'ils doivent
consentir pour parvenir à ce niveau de
performance ils gagnent très bien leur
vie quand on est une star de ce sport ce
qui était le cas pour k
bernique où on a encore mieux payés que
les autres on devrait avoir du point de
vue américain un devoir de réserve et ce
devoir il l'a brisé et il a brisé sur
une ligne qui était essentiel d'un point
de vue social aux états unis c'est à
dire que le sport
historiquement parlant avec la nfl mais
beaucoup la nfl a eu un effet
d'intégration c'est un fait
d'intégration sociale le football
américain c'est un sport où
multiethnique où aujourd'hui la
population noire à un grand rôle revenez
50 70 ans en arrière
le football est pratiqué par les blancs
les noirs étaient très peu admis il y
avait une équipe dont tout le monde
parlait au début parce qu'elle avait un
noir dans son dans son effectif
aujourd'hui c'est totalement intégré et
donc qu'à père nick est un petit peu
cassé cette belle mécanique il a franchi
une ligne rouge et il a été puni à un
moment parce que dans l'action il est
blacklisté maintenant colline copernic
mais pourquoi est ce que lui a pris et
pas tous les autres joueurs qu'on voit
ici mais trop ce que c'était l'honneur
parce que ce symbole c'était la mienne
j'aurais tendance à dire que justement
on se plaint que la société et les
sportifs sont un peu vide moi j'ai
apprécié le fait que comme une carpe et
rnic et un message social
d'ailleurs le sportif du 20e siècle
c'est mohamed ali mohamed ali a été
nommé sportif du xxème siècle parce que
justement il a pris un engagement social
donc que colin kaepernick prennent un
engagement social
moi ça me va donc le rôle le rôle du
sportif c'est quoi c'est ce cantonné aux
sports où c'est
c'est dans la société au plus large on
voit ce qui s'est passé notamment avec
le dakar en arabie saoudite les pilotes
qui ne s'engagent pas forcément le
discours d'hubert auriol qui dit c'est
pas aux sportifs de parler là on voit
colline copernic qui paraît ya des
sportifs en france on a par exemple
lilian thuram ou vikash dhorasoo en foot
qui parle c'est quoi le rôle du sportif
mais le rôle du sportif c'est d'avoir de
performer mais on peut pas oublier qu'un
sportif n'est pas juste un sportif c'est
un citoyen c'est un membre de notre
communauté qui à un moment a une idée
politique a une idée sociale et qui a
par sa plate forme parce que tout le
monde le regarde à un peu ce devoir de
pouvoir dire ce qui est bien ce qui
n'est pas bien en tous les cas pour
donner le tram c'était pas bien ce qui a
fait que link est mort on peut regarder
d'ailleurs le message de donald trump au
sujet de collines copernic s'il est
assez bon les équipes de nfl devrait le
recruter pourquoi l'engagerait tel ne
l'engagent ne l'engagerait tel pas s'il
était suffisamment bon seulement si son
niveau se relève suffisants rappelle il
est blacklisté là dessus c'est assez
drôle qu'il dit ça parce que jerry jones
le propriétaire des cowboys a avoué que
donald trump l'avait personnellement
appelé pour lui dire un de ne pas
engager copernic 2 de faire arrêter le
fait que les joueurs posent le genou au
sol pendant leur politique s'immisce
réel abondamment tombée alors le
problème si vous voulez c'est que en ce
qui concerne le caca pernik c'est une
forme de distraction du point de vue du
sportif pour être à quarterbacks à un
niveau requis ce sont des gens qui
prennent des coups tous les dimanches
c'est quand même très très brutal il
faut un investissement personnel qui ne
permet pas de faire de la politique
lundi et dette sur le stade le dimanche
il faut qu'on soit 100 à 150 % impliqués
dans ce sport et que les sportifs
aujourd'hui est une responsabilité
sociale
oui mais qu'ils la gardent pour après le
sport et qu'ils profitent de leur
notoriété pour en faire passer ce
message mais ensuite quand on est
sportif on est uniquement sportifs en
tout cas c'est la vision que donald
trump a il fallait pas que les deux se
mélangent
là c'est ce qui s'est passé récemment
on l'a vu il ya également dans le sud de
clément delcourt illégalement des
grandes marques qui ont voulu faire
passer à la fois lors leur côté
promotionnel évidemment mais en
utilisant la politique pour dire à
donald trump votre politique migratoire
on n'en veut pas est ce que c'est de la
sincérité de la part de toutes ces
marques ou est-ce que c'est simplement
une opération de communication marc
angelo soumah a tendance à dire les deux
parce que le cas le plus fort c'était le
fait que nike sponsor de la nfl engage
colline car pernik pour une pub où il
disait il faut y aller à fond même si ça
veut dire tout risque et donc il y a de
plus en plus cette immersion de la
politique dans d'autres sphères et avant
vous avez raison c'était vraiment
séparés mais au fur et à mesure que les
choses avancent mais on se rend compte
que on peut pas le sport n'est pas juste
un sanctuaire le sport on va représenter
notre société et si la société est
raciste et bien à un moment on va se
rendre compte que dans le sport il ya du
racisme et comment ça se passe dans le
vestiaire américaine dans le vestiaire
c'est tout bête d'un côté il ya les
noirs d'un côté il ya les blancs et a
les latinos qui sont entre les deux
aider les personnes évoluent avec leur
séparation
ce qui fait que on a beau avoir un peu
plus d'intégration
il ya des gens avec qui je jouais qui ne
me parlait pas en dehors du terrain tout
simplement parce que j'étais noir mais
et en français moi j'avais cette
possibilité de parler à tout le monde
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai été nommé
capitaine en général parce que moi je
parlais aux noirs ou blancs latinos
étant donné qu'un français nous on
connaît pas ça mais eux il y à une
représentation de leurs sociétés dans
leur vestiaire
le joueur qui va être nommé mvp cette
année est un quarterback noir il ya deux
ans celui ci allait être drafté et il y
avait des commentaires qui disaient il
est noir il est rapide il devrait
changer de position parce que
quarterbacks ça va être trop dur pour
lui c'est encore une réalité de leur
société mais justement alors pour pour
garder le verre à demi vide ou à demi
plein et c'est vrai que il ya une
trentaine d'années il n'y avait pas deux
quarterbacks noir n'y avait pas non plus
de coach d'entraîneur noire les noirs
étaient réservées pour certains postes
qui progressivement on avait été
parfaitement capable de tenir le job
on a vu comment s'appelait-il je veux ni
son nom mais le l'entraîneur des
steelers de pittsburgh mike tomlin très
bien merci mike tomlin a été faite à
noah a été le plus jeune entraîneur à
gagner un super bowl et aujourd'hui vous
avez ce phénomène d'intégration qui
fonctionne alors moi j'ai jamais connu
de vestiaire mais j'ai connu du côté du
spectateur les dimanches de football ou
avec les copains du boulot on fait tous
des paris et on se retrouve chez intel
pour regarder le match par les médias
c'est très convivial et paris illégaux
mais bon c'était avant internet tout ça
mais c'est convivial il ya beaucoup
d'intégration pour moi je suivais à san
francisco qui a toujours été une ville
avec une atmosphère qui était très très
très bien intégrés y avait pas de tous
trois de problèmes peut-être que
d'ailleurs ça s'était lié dire que
copernic était de 100 francs suisses
mais voilà est-ce qu'il a dit à san
francisco était pas forcément choquant
pour la population de san francisco plus
surprenant pour une amérique plus
conservatrices plus profond de plus
d'angoissé dans le kansas vous êtes
spécialiste de la politique aux
etats-unis gerald olivier cette année le
super bowl au niveau politique ce sera
quoi ce sera la destine le procès en
destitution de donner l'autre alors
justement à s'immiscer de dans ce cas
l'an dernier un pagne présidentielle la
lutte à distance entre washington et
téhéran
notez enterrant non à moi j'ai raté un
épisode mais téhéran n'ont par contre la
destitution inévitablement alors parce
que le calendrier particulier peut-être
que des démocrates l'ont souhaité comme
ça parce que c'est eux qui contrôlent l
le calendrier jusqu'à récemment et que
c'était un peu le vote en destitution
c'était le 18 décembre le procès aurait
pu commencer immédiatement c'est les
articles avaient été transmis au sénat
ça n'a pas été le cas madame pelosi qui
est la présidente de la chambre des
représentants a décidé de garder les
articles pour nous les transférer au
sénat que début janvier donc par là même
décidant de la date du début du procès
ce procès va durer entre deux semaines
et cinq ou six semaines
donc il est là on est toujours donnant
il n'est pas encore terminée et donc
inévitablement en semaine on parle
beaucoup de politique
peut-être que ce dimanche soir sera un
break et puis il faut savoir que lundi
matin
vous avez le vote de l'irak et la
première primaire
et vous avez juste après le discours sur
l'état de l'union donc le super bowl
vient dans ce moment médiatique un petit
peu surchargé pour l'élection l'élection
présidentielle a lieu le 3 novembre ce
sera oublié ce sera passé et pour moi
même d'ailleurs le procès en destitution
dont on connaît l'issue moi je concède
avance que monsieur jobs sera acquitté
est ce qu'il n'ya pas les votes pour le
condamner au sénat le procès sera ou non
pas oublié mais le reste est mis de côté
à ce moment là le mot de la fin selon
vous donc du coup sport politique
business et en pronostics quand même
alors j'aurais tendance à dire que oui
ça va s'immiscer forcément mais c'est du
sport c'est du business
ce qui est intéressant ce qu' ils ont
mis au milieu de ce spectacle sportif et
politique le sport ce qui fait qu'il ya
du contenu
et quand vous voyez les histoires des
joueurs et l'évolution à travers les
années vous voyez qu'il ya du contenu il
ya un vrai il ya des valeurs il ya
quelque chose dedans et donc votre
pronostic
quand ça san francisco comme un site et
vous gerald moi je serais pour san
francisco parce que j'ai vécu à san
francisco les fortunes haguenau c'est ma
grande équipe dont je vais regarder je
pense qu'ils l'emporteront je l'espère
en tout cas je reste 150 % avec eux une
soirée en tous les cas à suivre en votre
compagnie sur bin sport ce dimanche à
partir de 23h30 une édition spéciale sur
votre antenne
merci beaucoup marc angelo soumah
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
également à vous gérald olivier un autre
match spécial donc super bowl à revivre
également sur internet arte france point
tv en replay et en podcast et on se
donne rendez vous la semaine prochaine
évidemment pour une nouvelle émission un
spécial l'autre match
[Musique]